it's finally time I talk about ozampic
it's been called The Not So secret
Miracle weight loss drug of Hollywood
Elite it's been rumored to be linked to
the Kardashians recent body
Transformations and celebrities like
Mindy Kaling and it's been confirmed
that it's helped other major players
like Elon Musk drop some serious lbs but
some media reports have not been so kind
the guardian for example coined it an
eating disorder in an injection or the
Clockwork Orange for junk food while
body positive activists like Aubry
Gordon see it as society's last ditch
effort to get rid of fat people for good
but regardless of the backlash it's
quickly become one of the hottest
hashtags on Tick Tock aside from Botox
and maybe Viagra it seems like osempic
is now one of the most recognizable
Pharma brand names of Our Generation
most gen Zeds and Millennials are now
more tuned with ozempic news than local
politics world worldwide disasters a
global pandemic or the weather in our
own backyard not surprisingly the social
media Buzz alone is now believed to be
the lead cause of a shortage in the
United States and this shortage has
people fired the [__] up it honestly
feels a little scary to be even talking
about this as a straight-sized anti-diet
culture dietitian but I'm finally ready
to try to clear the air folks let's talk
about ozone pick hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
this is
today we'll be discussing the notorious
Tick Tock endorsed weight loss drug
ozempic and its lesser-known cousins
mongero and wagovi but first I want of
course to put up a key disclaimer here
we're going to be talking about weight
loss explicitly and in some cases
Extreme Weight Loss so please feel free
to skip this if it's not supportive to
your journey also a huge thank you to
Eric Williamson dietitian and PhD who
specializes in sports and weight
management if you're not already
following him check out his Instagram
below and get in touch for any
one-on-one support that I can personally
endorse also friends please subscribe if
you like this video it really really
does help me out and of course follow me
on Tick Tock and Instagram at Abby's
kitchen okay this is gonna change the
game and by game I mean my sleep because
if you've been a long time subby here
you know that getting a good sleep can
be a bit of a tricky game for this girl
this is eight sleep pod cover and it's
finally transformed my bed into the
perfect sleeping conditions for me I run
very hot especially at night while my
husband is always complaining that it's
too cold and the Pod cover allows us to
set the temperature of our bed
differently so that we can both be
comfortable at the same time so you can
set the temperature between 55 and 110
degrees Fahrenheit and obviously you
know your girl is going right down to
the North Pole because that is how I
like you and it's not just about Comfort
this is science folks sleep science
shows us that our bodies fall asleep
best when our temperature drops one to
three degrees Fahrenheit then getting
into deep REM sleep may require even
lower attempts and then when we need to
wake up the temperature should climb but
the Pod monitors temperature and adjusts
it up and down to keep you in the
optimal zone for your bed your body
temperature and the environment the Pod
cover also tracks and collects data
while you sleep without out you having
to wear any kind of uncomfortable
wearable device and you can set your
morning wake up as a gentle chest level
vibration and a gradual increase in
temperature because obnoxious alarm
clocks are so 2019 and I realize this is
a higher ticket item but speaking as an
insomniac I just believe you cannot put
a price on really good sleep we have
ample evidence that sleep is one of the
most important modifiable factors
contributing to health Mental Health
weight management Stress Management
immunity cognitive health and lower risk
of chronic diseases are all linked to
better sleep and their numbers really
speak for themselves pod sleepers fall
asleep 44 faster and get 34 deeper
sleeps like that is music to your girl's
ears so if you want to try with the Pod
cover yourself check out my link in the
description and use my promo code Abby
to get 150 fifty dollars off of your
order so first of all this video has
been a long time coming and a much
needed follow-up to a now deleted Tick
Tock that I posted back in January of
this year we need to talk about this
latest weight loss magic drug that is
taking social media and Hollywood by
storm in that video I attempted to
Simply give the facts about ozempic in a
quick 60 seconds I mentioned that it was
a diabetes medication being used off
label for weight loss that there was a
shortage now due to its popularity and
what you could expect for weight loss
success monthly price and also weight
regain when you came off the drugs and
well a lot of you got my message
especially those who were the first to
watch it others were upset that it felt
like I was insinuating that folks with
obesity should be kind of second fiddle
through those with diabetes who for
according to some authorities should be
prioritized for a coveted dose that
absolutely wasn't my intention but there
really is only so much new wants that I
can give in 60 seconds hence why I'm now
going to tell you in a lot more detail
how I actually feel about this new wave
of weight loss drugs and some of you
might be shocked with my take so let's
start with some cold hard facts first of
all as many of you guys know ozempic is
not even a medication for weight loss
it's currently only approved for
diabetes but the active ingredient in
ozamic smelglatide is also found in a
drug that is approved for obesity called
wegovi now when we go the demand outdid
Supply earlier on in this year doctors
started to prescribe ozempic off label
for weight loss because the active
ingredient was the same but then like
the great toilet paper gate of March
2020 news reports claimed that ozempic
also was becoming hard to get not only
for folks Now using it for obesity but
also for those with diabetes who had
been taking the drug for years now the
final player here is munjaro but the
active drug here is something called
terrazepatide which has slightly
different properties that I'm going to
discuss in a moment but like osempic at
this time of filming at least it's only
approved for diabetes though it is also
being prescribed off label for obesity
so why the sudden spike in demand with
these new age weight loss drugs well
probably partially celebrities partially
Tick-Tock testimonials partially
lingering coveted pounds and mostly the
fact they honestly really do work before
we had smell glotide or tear zepatide we
had a bunch of other weight loss drugs
with less than Stellar track records
most resulted in about five to eight
percent weight loss on average but came
with a laundry list of not so sexy side
effects like loss of voice difficulty
breathing anxiety insomnia or the
dreaded orlastat anal leakage not sure I
would be okay with my ass leaking to
just lose five percent but hey
everyone's priorities and values will
differ now as an upgrade most studies on
smell good hide suggest it results in
about 15 percent loss of body weight
when paired with healthy lifestyle
interventions like diet and exercise so
that is a pretty dramatic leap in my
books now tear zepatide which is the
active ingredient in munjaro is
potentially even more promising and
while it hasn't been directly compared
to a dose of somalglotide typically
provided for weight loss preliminary
evidence suggests that it may result in
up to 20 to 25 percent of body weight
loss possibly even more for some folks
so what are these drugs doing anyway
well we go the ozempic and munjaro are
all glp-1 agonists AKA glucagon like
peptide 1 agonists the word Agonist
means it acts similarly to our body's
natural hormone glp1 and this hormone
has a multitude of benefits but in short
it helps to slow down food absorption in
the stomach so you feel Fuller longer it
regulates in insulin and blood sugars
and most importantly it tells the brain
that you are full now munjaro is not
only a glp1 Agonist but it's also a Gip
Agonist AKA glucose dependent
insulotropic polypeptide yes the combo
of those two very very long words seems
to have synergistic effects making
mojaro more powerful than just a glp1
Agonist alone and this is why it seems
to be more effective and decided to
overtake the ozempic and way Govi craze
though research is still in its infancy
but back to why ozempic and its cousins
are causing rapid weight loss in so many
folks ultimately these drugs
significantly suppress hunger and this
tends to make achieving a calorie
deficit a lot easier in fact it's been
shown to reduce calorie intake by 35
without changing people's perceived
hunger levels in the day in other words
you can eat a lot less and not feel
hungry and this unique mechanism is
arguably the essential key to long-term
weight loss success this drug is
essentially suppressing the body's
natural compensatory mechanisms that
kick into high gear whenever we are put
in a calorie deficit normally when we're
on a diet our body fights to maintain
body weight homeostasis by increasing
our hunger hormones and decreasing
satiety hormones in this desperate
effort to make us eat more and as I
discussed in my video on weight loss
right here this is one of the many
reasons why long-term weight maintenance
is really hard without medications like
ozonepic the body is programmed to ramp
up that appetite with every extra pound
of body weight we lose some research
even suggests that these hunger
adaptations persist for years after the
diet ends I mean we talked about extreme
hunger on this channel this is basically
it now aside from the physical hunger
ozaro also help to reduce cravings and
help people feel more in control with
their food intake again this is
revolutionary in the weight loss world
because typically people who have lost
weight experience more cravings and less
satisfaction after eating which in turn
can derail long-term efforts so bottom
line these weight loss drugs are not
magic they still require a calorie
deficit to work but because of the
impact on physical satiety and
psychological satisfaction they make
obtaining that deficit much much easier
so those are the facts but now we gotta
touch on the juicy controversies
surrounding this drug and the great
shortage of 2023. so let's start with
the million dollar question that has
rocked people's worlds who is worthy of
obtaining this drug should we be
prioritizing folks with a disease like
diabetes when people in larger bodies
should just be kind of putting in the
work at the gym there's a lot to unpack
you've all seen the horror story race on
Tick Tock and other news outlets from
folks who are prescribed ozethic for
diabetes needing to like cross state
lines just to find a single dose of
their life-saving meds when you imagine
the stress and anxiety of being unable
to fulfill a prescription because it's
going to an unofficial demographic you
know you could probably appreciate and
empathize with the anger frustration and
fear on the flip side it's worth
pointing out that obesity not unlike
diabetes is also recognized officially
as a chronic disease worthy of medical
support and that is done by authorities
like obesity Canada the Canadian Medical
Association the American Medical
Association and the World Health
Organization so we know that this is in
Stark opposition to the teachings of
haze or health at every size but you
guys know by now that I don't personally
identify with all aspects of that
movement I do think that for some folks
weight loss may help to support their
physical health and their psychological
well-being I also try to follow the
science as objectively as possible and
the science tells us that not unlike
someone with diabetes needing
pharmaceutical support for blood sugar
management many folks with obesity may
need medical intervention to override
some of the genetic factors responsible
for differences in reward response
hunger and fullness cues and propensity
to gain weight in today's environment
which brings me to the importance of
genetics and why some folks may not be
able to dramatically shift their set
point weight without some form of
medical intervention winking and weight
loss capabilities are genetically
determined some people will naturally
experience higher appetite or a greater
dopamine spikes from food or lower
rewards stimulation from exercise
greater relief from stress from over
consumption a stronger drive to eat when
experiencing negative emotions or lower
sense of fullness from calorie
consumption alone research on twins
separated and raised by two different
families have found that obesity is
actually about 70 percent genetically
determined and only 30 percent
environment hence the adage genetics
load the gun and environment pulls the
trigger likewise some people are going
to experience more negative Health
outcomes when living with obesity than
others this is not a homogeneous group
so we cannot judge a book by its cover
here body weight does not equal Health
outcomes it is so much more complex than
that and this is not a homogeneous group
so we really do need to look at the
individual to determine if adding in
medication to complement a healthy
lifestyle would be right and supportive
for them and it's worth emphasizing that
even with medication the recommendations
do still focus on nutrition exercise and
lifestyle intervention as the first line
of defense both before during and of
course after medical obesity treatment
so no one here is suggesting that taking
a weight loss drug like a zempic is a
free ride and speaking of Free Ride
these medications are not without side
effects the most common side effect is
nausea followed by some of the other
usual GI suspects thankfully most people
report that nausea declines pretty
steadily over time but for a lot of
folks it's completely debilitating with
a lot of users describing being suddenly
repulsed by even seeing their favorite
foods and some even report being turned
off or filled up too quickly by water
which can potentially put one at risk
for dehydration as well there are also
more potentially dangerous side effects
like thyroid cancer seen in animal
research plus pancreatitis or gall
stones but not unlike the birth control
pill antidepressants or even an
antibiotic medicine is all about a risk
and benefit analysis it's all about
weighing the potential discomforts or
risks with the potential benefits both
immediately and long term different
people are going to react differently
and for for some those risks or
discomforts won't outweigh the benefits
of the medication and this is why it's
so important to work with your health
care team to determine if an
intervention like this is right for you
yes I know I sound like these sped up
disclaimers in a pharmaceutical
infomercial right now but seriously
everyone's experiences will be unique
but let's move along to talk about the
elephant in the room if you started
taking ozepik to lose some weight do you
now need to stay on it for life well if
you want to keep the weight off for Life
probably yes research suggests that one
year after coming off of ozempic
orwigovi participants gained on average
two-thirds of the weight right back and
this really isn't a surprise because as
we established earlier on the main
reason why we see such success with this
medication Beyond just lifestyle habits
is because it helps to counteract The
increased appetite associated with
weight loss but if we go off the drug
and now we're at a lower body weight are
appetite like dramatically rages not
only to its normal pre-drug levels but
maybe even higher as our body fights to
get us back to its preferred set point
weight there may be some patients who
can slowly wean while maintaining a very
strict diet and exercise regimen but I
would expect it to feel like a real
struggle after having this
pharmaceutical boost so tell probably
what you really think Abby first of all
I believe in body autonomy I say it all
the time and I don't think that one
chronic disease cohort is more worthy
than another of access to a potentially
life-saving or life-changing drug it's
really a shame that we need to triage
patients or turn getting a prescription
into like a modern Hunger Games
especially because there's already so
much stigma and shame for folks in
larger bodies trying to access
supportive care if a medication can help
them regain their Mobility metabolic
health happiness confidence whatever I
am all here for it that said I have a
lot of fears for one I'm worried that
social media and Hollywood culture are
positioning these drugs as like a fast
easy solution for rapid weight loss that
they're just something you can take when
you want to fit into a certain gal
address or for like a bikini vacation
and then you can go off it again when
you want to have a cheat day with your
girls I also worry that due to shortages
and Desperation that people will seek
out unregulated compounded cocktails
underground for some completely bogus
reasons generic simulglutide is exempt
from normal FDA approval so a lot of
pharmacies and Medi Spas are now
offering their own weight loss cocktails
that they compound themselves often for
much cheaper than the brand name but
experts are warning that because it is
unregulated and untested these
compounded prescriptions could be
ineffective at best and dangerous at
worst so in my books it's really not
worth taking the risk I also fear that
people will see this as a replacement
for physical activity and a balanced
nutrient-dense diet the research
suggests that a large proportion of
weight loss while taking these
medications is lean muscle mass around
39 of the weight lost according to one
study so for not supporting the farm
pharmaceutical regimen with a
protein-rich diet and resistance
exercise we may potentially be making
ourselves more metabolically healthy in
one way at the expense of another and
I've been focusing on health here but
not surprisingly the internet has been
focusing on the exemptic aesthetic most
notoriously the now stigmatized exemptic
face this is a whole other topic worth
unpacking related to ageism classism and
access but from a nutritional
perspective I just think it's a good
reminder that nutrition really does
still matter here and ozemic users do
need to focus on having a high quality
diet to maintain muscle mass with such
rapid weight loss finally again another
huge massive topic that needs a whole
other video to unpack but I am terrified
about the long-term implications on
General body dysmorphia and what is even
considered a normal healthy weight I
wouldn't have concerns if these drugs
were only being used as in 10 it for
folks with chronic obesity or diabetes
but when every already slim celebrity
and influencer is now another 20 pounds
smaller how are we as a society going to
feel about healthy size women like me
like is this going to be the new obese
of 2025 of course on an extreme end I'm
concerned about these drugs being abused
in Ed communities as like a not so
secret weight loss hack but even without
a history of dieting or disordered
eating when we start to only see ozampic
bodies represented in the media the goal
post for an acceptable body gets further
and further away okay obviously this is
me going down like a doomsday rabbit
hole and I'm hoping that none of these
things occur because I do think that
these medications are life-saving for
the intended populations but we all live
in a social media Echo chamber where the
small snippet of the world that we see
is typically what we perceive to be fact
and true of the World At Large so I just
hope that celebrity ozembic bodies don't
become the only official true look of
Wellness going forward so in conclusion
I think there is absolutely an important
role for medications like ozempic
specifically for folks with diabetes and
for folks with obesity whose weight is
putting them at higher risk of Health
implications and issues or for whom
Lifestyle Changes alone have not been
successful but this is not to help
people drop the last bit of baby weight
this is not to help you fit into your
wedding dress that you bought a size too
small this is nutrition medical therapy
for a chronic disease intended to be
used for life and even if you do for the
Target criteria and demographic taking
ozympic is not a quick fix invitation to
never exercise or eat a vegetable again
lifestyle support is going to be
critical for long-term success and
muscle preservation so I strongly
suggest working with a registered
dietitian on your journey if you're
seeking out one-on-one support yourself
whether it's for weight loss with or
without pharmaceutical support I
strongly recommend Eric Williamson for
his one-on-one coaching you can check
him out at
unlockedfitnessnutrition.com and follow
him at unlocked Fitness and Nutrition on
Instagram and Tick Tock I expect the
research and recommendations around
drugs like ozempic will quickly grow I
mean diabetes drugs will be approved for
obesity new competing drugs will be
developed and the price of everything
will inevitably fall making these
medications more accessible to the lay
person so I'll be keeping my finger on
the pulse for an updated video in the
meantime if you guys like this video
please be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below if you have any
questions about these drugs subscribe to
the channel and I'll see you next time
on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
all right now I need a snack because I
am hungry